the Joe Rogan experience yeah I feel
that resilience is almost like a muscle
it's something that you can build and
it's also something they can get soft
and I think that I look I love comfort
don't get me wrong but I don't
appreciate it unless I've done something
difficult you know if you look at like
all the different things I do and say
are you real productive and that's nice
dude I also like to watch TV I like to
put my feet up I like to kick back like
to have beer I like to relax but I don't
like to relax if I'm not doing [ __ ] I
know me and I get mad at me if I'm not
doing anything
I don't like me when I'm not productive
but when I am productive I also can
enjoy to relax
I enjoy relaxation and I don't enjoy it
unless I've earned it and I think that's
what people need to do they they need to
earn their comfort you have a proper
sense of shame which is what you're
describing that's chapter six it's
called the right you're describing this
stuff because you already know this like
if you read my book like you'll be like
I already know all this but because it's
true all right now I'm trying to give
these lessons out in a clear and
coherent kind of fun way but these
things are just true you feel bad when
you don't act the way you envision
yourself to be like you you have this
hero archetype and I talked about here
are archetypes before you have this idea
of like what you think is the right way
to be and you're trying to live up to
that at all times we often fail and
you've built that archetype over time
maybe looking to others it's like the
right kind of hero maybe you've seen how
how successful people are and you're
like I want to be like that I'm sure
maybe you're doing comedy or fighting or
whatever it is like you're like they
have a way of doing something that maybe
I should mendicancy built this over time
and you know when you you know only you
know really when you when you don't meet
that standard when you don't meet that
standard there should be a degree of
shame that you feel and and I and I
again this is a problem I've viewed in
society where I don't know that people
are feeling that shame anymore it's
almost the opposite and when you when
you don't feel that shame you can't feel
a sense of duty to be that citizen that
we talked about earlier and I find this
to be a big problem even with the small
stuff like and I use examples in the
book like you should feel shame when
you're that person who doesn't put the
shopping cart in the little shopping
cart section yeah parking lot and said
leaves it in the parking space
absolutely no it's easy and you're like
ah somebody will do it there's people
there people who take care of this well
but like why why don't you just want you
just put it away and worsley and if you
don't put it away because you're in a
rush you know because your kid is
screaming and maybe have a good reason
not to put it away but the question that
to ask yourself is did you feel bad
about it
right did you feel bad about it and if
you didn't feel bad about it what the
hell is wrong with you these are very
simple lessons that we have to start
small have to start small the shopping
cart one is a great example that's such
a good one this is a classic it's so
good this makes you mad that's like I've
found the greatest parking spot and then
that damn carts like so easy to do just
just put it back [ __ ] just walk it over
there put it in the little stall and you
feel better you like look I did it I you
know what I do I bring it all the way
the [ __ ] back to the supermarket
accomplish stuff I put it back in the
thing right in front yes I don't I don't
even put it in the stall I walk those
extra steps and it doesn't take much
time but I feel like I did something
even if it's just a trick the grocery
store doesn't even have to put those
little sections out in the parking lot
they could just tell you to put it walk
it all the way back like a door [ __ ]
leave but the reason why I like the
little stalls is because of people that
do have kids if there's a mom and she's
got a baby with her gray give her an way
out or hire some kid to gather those
things up while people are walking out
with them fine but you know if you're
just a guy and you you know you're
shopping for yourself and you don't put
your car back [ __ ] you you know and that
sense of shame that you're talking about
that that really is important people
need to feel shame if you've come up
short like that because you can do
better you can do better and you should
want to do better the way to get back
the way to get ahead in life is to do
everything that way the way you do
everything is the way
do anything the way you do anything is
the way you do everything I mean that's
really what it is if you just do the
right thing do it the way you're
supposed to do it you can do it and
you'll feel better if you're supposed to
get a workout in today like [ __ ] I'd
rather just sleep in no just [ __ ] get
your ass up and do it and you'll feel
better when it's done you're like damn I
did it I can do this tomorrow too you
can and it's momentum and just
developing that momentum it's a skill
it's like everything else it's like
learning how to be polite it's like
learning how to be cordial learning how
to be a nice person these are learned
things you can't just accept that you're
a piece of [ __ ] and this is just the way
you are no just look at yourself as if
you are another person judging you like
as if you are a person who's like a life
coach judging you what would you tell
you to do that's exactly right
and the reason I reason I wrote about
this was because you know throughout
this book I'm identifying a problem and
then trying to come up with a solution
so the solution is effectively saying
what you're saying and I write a lot
about it I write about the psychology
behind it but the problem is is like we
I feel like we've removed shame in our
culture to a huge extent to where it's
where it's almost celebrated to you know
to like do these wrong things we've
started to change the definition of
what's right and wrong then this sort of
kind of post postmodern society and we
think with some examples of what I mean
by that well in and one part I do bring
up the example of of how we view you
know assistance like government
assistance and there's the movie
Cinderella Man where Russell Crowe plays
the whatever the name is of a boxer yeah
that's a and you know he gets a welfare
check the beginning the movie by the end
of the movies pulled himself back up and
he returns it and that's sort of like
our classic heroic thing to do like you
know what like we believe in helping
people to need it but we also believe
that you shouldn't take it if you don't
need it it seems like a pretty good good
piece of you know civic duty to live by
and then I look to my own experience
leaving the Navy where we were actually
encouraged to get on Social Security
disability insurance as I was leaving
the Navy so I was in a classroom full of
Oh fellow of Navy servicemembers none of
which were seals none of which had been
in combat
none of which appeared injured in any
way I was the only one with like a
visible injury or it's obvious as to why
I'm being medically retired and so we're
all getting medically retired and by
nature of getting medically retired from
the military it's guaranteed that we
have some kind of benefit on the back
end of that and I what I would call a
very generous benefit you know people
would disagree with me on that but I
think it's a I think we get a generous
benefit and - on to say on top of that
that we should also take money out of
the Social Security trust fund for
disability insurance even though every
single person in their walk right out of
that classroom is perfectly capable of
working was so frightening to me that it
would that it is so ingrained in our new
culture that that it was actually in the
curriculum at a government classroom um
and and this time of stuff is cheered on
you know and I see this a lot people
will tell a story of victimhood and be
cheered but we're not supposed to cheer
for that we might feel compassion for
them but to cheer for them and this this
explains why we're seeing these sort of
hoaxes that we've seen like why did
Jesse small that feel that he had to say
that to Mogga guys and Chicago beat him
up why did what was we we didn't ask
enough what the underlying psychology
behind that was think why do that and I
think the reason is because we started
to elevate victimhood to elevate this
sir shame will be hate and this is what
I mean by we sort of changed the
definitions of what it even means to
feel ashamed and what it means to feel
like you're doing the wrong thing
because we've changed the definitions of
right and wrong and I and I see a need
to get us back to some traditional
definitions before we all just lose our
freaking minds
yeah I think that's that's a very good
point I think what you're saying is
absolutely correct
I think victimhood should be look if you
are an actual victim
I mean I feel for you it's terrible but
if you're not a victim and you're
playing up victimhood
it's disgusting it's one of the grossest
things that you see in our culture
especially when we're talking about how
easy society is and now when you have a
person who is affluent and successful
and famous like Jesse Smollett who does
that and you like Jesus Christ man like
boy did you miss the point that's why
it's so foul for us when we see someone
who's just trying to for their own
personal gain they're trying to game the
system and make it out like they're a
victim it's one of the grossest things
that you could see in a successful
culture I mean there's people out there
that really are injured like yourself
from combat there's people out there
that really are sick there's people out
there that are really victimized by
violent crime and to fake it it's such a
it's such a disgusting insult to people
that actually are injured yeah and
that's that's like the most extreme I
think that that's the extreme
consequence of this victim agriculture
because there's definitely different
real victims in victimhood culture you
have to distinguish between those two
things and we have to respect somebody
who's actually a victim yes you know in
my case and the disability insurance
thing like I didn't take it but what
concerns me is that if I had taken it
and and if I had gone on and said in and
sort of proudly explained that I got
this and I needed it like shouldn't
somebody call me out for that you know
and the reality is is I don't think
people would I don't think I would be
called out for that even though I'm a
perfectly capable of work yes I'm kind
of blind and like I can't see even out
of my good eye but I can work I mean
I've shown that I can work why would I
take that that that wouldn't be just
that would I think that would go against
our classical definition of what is fair
and just and yet in our current culture
I do I don't believe that anybody would
call me out for that and I should be
called out if I had taken that money I
really believe that just because I was
already getting benefits right I'm not
saying it shouldn't get anything I was
blown up and then had to get out of the
Navy as a result but but i but I feel
our culture's a little bit backwards on
this
[Applause]